bonsoir alioune merci d'être avec nous
en direct sur rt france les rend la vue
qui continue malgré des appels à
manifester de façon pacifique de
l'opposant sont co et les appels au
calme du président macky sall pourquoi
un tel mouvement de colère est ce qu'on
peut craindre clairement un basculement
écoute irlandais proche du basculement
effectivement c'est pour ça qu'il ya eu
beaucoup d'initiatives mais ils
s'activent pour parler au président de
la république parle également à
l'opposition pour effectivement à la
fois permettre la libération de cerveau
est ce que c'est
c'est ça qui a suscité beaucoup de
colère et en même temps aussi demandé à
l'opposition de suspendre les
manifestations parce que les
manifestations donné lieu à des
violences
il nuit qu'on n'a jamais qu'on n'a
jamais vus au sénégal
donc je fasse que les deux côtés les
gens compris dans les messages il ya eu
des appels à l'apaisement surtout on a
été très surpris par le message du
président rahim également pas le message
de sorgho tout en étant dans le registre
de l'opposant dans les collines sont
quoi après quand même des déclarations
assez laids pour dire vraiment qu'ils ne
voudraient pas de prise du pouvoir par
là et qu'ils ne voulaient pas la prise
du pouvoir également aussi par l'armée
je fasse des déclarations extrêmement
importante au moment où tout le monde
sentait le basculement du sénégal 20
vers l'inconnu cela dit aussi soro a
fait appel à militer national et devra
formuler des revendications dans tout ça
il faut voir que battre l'opposition
joue on peut aussi la survie politique
joue aussi pour que la question du
troisième mandat qui est derrière tout
l'été que cette question aussi pu être
abordés abordé également aussi la
possibilité pour khalifa sall et puis
karim ouannes et la demande de
participer à des élections je pense
qu'on a eu une démocratie qui a été qui
a été volé on a eu la peau vite qui a
été un autre facteur aggravant et à lui
effectivement la faire son come vraiment
la goutte d'eau qui a permis de
déclencher toute cette affaire est
vraiment maintenant les gens qui
comprennent que pratiquement sûr si
aussi sur la corde raide et qu'il faut
arrêter parce que les jeux il
ils ne travaillent pas les jeunes n'ont
plus la possibilité m'a ma question
pardonnez moi de vous couper c'était ma
question suivante ce sont les jeunes
clairement qui composent ce mouvement de
contestation d'ailleurs on a mis un
extrait restera aux réseaux sociaux
peut-être un petit peu pour pour museler
cette jeunesse qui qui manifestent c'est
c'est une jeunesse sans perspective une
jeunesse symbolisons c'est le jet ski
qui a l'habitude de prendre tous les
risques
en attendant il s'en va condamner dans
des pirogues pour prendre vraiment le
mais avec tous les risques qu'ils
connaissent ils sont conscients les
familles sont conscientes qu'il peut
perdre mais dans une juriste qui n'a
absolument rien à faire de radicaliser
déterminé je laisse aussi s'ouvrir et 6
aussi ce gaulliste patriotes comme il
s'appelle donc cette jeunesse qui a été
touchée de chômage par les effets
pervers de la pandémie que 8,19 et kaki
qui a pris d'assaut les magasins auchan
également se servir sa liste des émeutes
de la faim parce qu'effectivement on vit
dans une société où facture sociale et
les femmes les inégalités sociales sont
énormes d'un côté vous avez une espèce
de de noblesse d'état et de l'autre côté
surtout quand vous allez dans les
banlieues
les gens ont toutes les peines du monde
effectivement également se nourrir
c'est tout ça qui est qui qui inverse à
la faveur de cette question plus la
question du 3è mandat mais il faut il
faut effectivement être extrêmement
vigilantes du côté de l'état d'abord
pour ne pas trop tirer sur la corde
du côté de l'opposition aussi vous ne
partirez sur l'accord parce que et à
l'expérience du mali l'expérience du
mali ou en terrasse sur accor pouvoir
nous sommes dans une situation
extrêmement difficile au mali donc à
tous cette expérience vraiment beaucoup
de bonne volonté les religieux la
société civile notamment ont vu les deux
parties pour arriver à cette calme que
j'estime encore précaire il faut
toujours travailler pour essayer de
consolider à voir les dialogues
l'opposition et le pouvoir et de mettre
sur la table
toutes les questions contentieuse parce
qu'aujourd'hui on est en train de poser
la justice judiciaire comme ils disent
et une justice pour reculer roi ça c'est
le signe de l'effondrement carrément de
l'institution judiciaire
surtout de la défiance des populations
par rapport à l'institution judiciaire
mais de la même manière aussi on ne peut
pas soutenir à une justice populaire
travail et avoir une justice
indépendante
avoir une justice impartiale une justice
qui puisque effectivement s'attaquer au
contentieux politique parce que c'est ça
le problème
souvent on se sert la justice pénale
pour écarter les opposants politiques et
on se sert également de la cour
constitutionnelle où le conseil
constitutionnel
enfin effective à permettent de
déverrouiller la limitation manar on a
compris le message en tout cas merci
pardonnez moi on arrive à la fin de cet
intérimaire si elle une dinh d'avoir été
avec nous à voir exposer votre analyse
sur la situation au sénégal merci à vous